as an immortal superhero diana prince
spends her life encountering all sorts
of friends and foes but whether she's
facing a god of war
or low-level mischief diana handles
everyone she meets with compassion
grace and a golden lasso here are the
characters in wonder woman 1984
with more meaning than viewers might
realize early in wonder woman 1984
audiences visit diana's metropolitan dc
apartment
filled with books on archaeology and
cultural anthropology
plus some mementos nodding to the
previous film one black and white photo
looks like a wedding celebration that
reunited the ragtag commandos who helped
her during world war one
samia charlie and chief but a separate
photo shows diana some years after the
war
standing in front of a city skyline
alongside etta candy a female friend
from those early days etta wears glasses
and looks greyer compared to diana who
as an immortal superhero looks unchanged
but the actor accredited as attorney
wonder woman 1984
even in this brief moment it's still
lucy davis who played her in the 2017
film
in the comics etta was wonder woman's
closest friend a korea air force officer
who later becomes a government agent the
2017 film made her steve trevor's
secretary
who awkwardly carried diana's sword and
shield and liked diana's feisty nurse
instantly
etta preferred using her principles to
fight mostly anyway
where do you think you're going entire p
the military leader of the amazons of
themyscira
and considered their greatest warrior
died in 2017's wonder woman but a
flashback in wonder woman 1984
brings her to life again once more
portrayed by robin wright
wright loved playing entire p the first
time around telling scream rant what is
the message of wonder woman that is so
timely
we need to hear more of this because
it's just about love and equality and
justice
in wonder woman 1984 entire p teaches
diana a lesson about honesty
the sister of diana's mother queen
hippolyta and tayo p
introduced his young diana to an
athletic contest featuring gymnastics
swimming equestrian skills and archery
she also gives her a little bit of
advice both for the competition and life
in general
just do your best and remember
greatness is not what you think the
scrappy diana is ahead of the game for a
while
until the branch knocks her off her
horse she scrambles down a hill
taking a shortcut to catch up with her
mount but antiope stops her short of the
finish line
she then tells her niece you're not
ready to win and there is no shame in
that
no true hero is born from lies her
aunt's wise words stay with diana years
later
as does her tiara which she balancer
gave to diana before she left home
in the 2017 film barbara minerva better
known as cheetah
is one of wonder woman's longtime foes
in the comics barbara is an
archaeologist and professor
interested in the civilization of the
amazons diana and barbara become friends
but their friendship turned sour after
barbara goes on an expedition to
investigate the ancient god as kataga
earthquake captures barbara who agrees
by the promise of immortality
to be his tribe's new guardian she
drinks a potion that turns her into a
feline human
complete with orange skin black spots
claws and a tail although wonder woman
1984 revamps its origin story to a
considerable extent
it keeps certain elements notably the
spark of friendship between the two
this time around barbara is a gorky
geologist gemologist and part-time
cryptozoologists who is in ore of
diana's beauty
strength and ability to walk in cheetah
print heals after the fbi asked the
smithsonian to identify certain relics
one of which turns out to be a
wish-granting stone
barbara wishes she could be just like
diana inadvertently gaining super speed
strength and agility like the short
story the monkey's poor the wishes
involve some dire consequences but
barbara won't renounce her wish
determined never to be an awkward
doormat again
wealthy businessman and entrepreneur
maxwell lord has been knocking around
the dc universe since the 1980s
at one point in the comics playing a key
role in organizing the superhero team
known as justice league international
during the late 1980s crossover event
invasion
readers learned that lord was actually a
meta human with mind control abilities
but this character's extensive backstory
also includes other affiliations
including the black lantern corps
the illuminati and the extremists that
said wonder woman
1984 director patty jenkins told people
that their version of lord is more
inspired by controversial headline
grabbing business mavericks like bernie
madoff and donald trump
pedro pascal currently the dadalorian to
the famous baby yoda on the mandalorian
star wars series
plays lord as a would-be oil tycoon with
blonde hair big ambitions and the
intense desperation of a guy out to
prove he's not a loser
meanwhile the character has a young son
who loves him just fine the way he is
pascal who memorably played the viper
oberyn martel on game of thrones
incidentally has another title wonder
woman he appeared as the indelically
named character
edin delicato in the unreleased wonder
woman tv pilot from 2011 which starred
adrian palicki as diana
us air force pilot steve trevor has been
wonder woman's love interest since the
1940s so it was natural to introduce a
romance between steve and diana in the
2017 film
as steve chris pine had such natural
chemistry with gal gadot
that even though his character died the
filmmakers wanted to bring him back in
some capacity
despite the death-defying return steve's
comeback made sense for the characters
and the actors both
as pine told entertainment weekly
there's parity in the relationship and
they support one another they bring out
the best parts of one another diana
doesn't mean to bring steve back from
the dead in wonder woman 1984.
she just wishes around that magical
stone that she could see him again
but she hasn't been in love since their
time together during world war one
and still misses him dearly we won't
spoil how things turn out for this
timeless couple
except to say that steve once again
makes diana's heart sore
when steve trevor comes back from the
dead his spirit actually inhabits the
body of another guy
built only in the credits as handsome
man something we'll bet amuses actor
christopher balohar to no end when steve
and diana first reunite the handsome
mana tagalog gives her a watch and
repeats his passing words from the 2017
film
i wish we had more time the bewildering
moment for diana develops into something
magical
as a man transforms in diana's eyes to
the steve she loves but the
cinematography and an occasional mirror
made clear that while she and the
audience see piner steve the other
characters see the unnamed man
when the woman 1984 doesn't provide any
backstory for the mysterious guy
but paloha is a familiar face in his own
right the veteran actor has made
appearances on tv shows like madmen
castle and ballers he's also set to
appear in the third entry in the
jurassic world
series jurassic world dominion in one
action sequence diana and steve chase
after a military convoy protecting
maxwell lord
who through the power of the wishing
stone has acquired both the oil
and the bodyguards of emir saeed bin
abados played by amra waked
lord have been jealous of the emir he
was featured on a magazine cover around
the same time that lord's less than
effective wells
seemed to be little more than a ponzi
scheme the emir at first scoffs at the
idea that lord could offer him anything
he might want
then looks over the city of cairo in
egypt and wishes that his ancestral
lands could be returned
the film doesn't explain the politics
behind the emir's wish
but it's granted in a snap causing chaos
for people in the region
although his role is brief viewers might
recognize wakeed a native of cairo as
comedian rami yusef's father on the hulu
comedy series rami
waked has also appeared in siriana lucy
geostorm
and netflix's marco polo series diana
has several co-workers at the
smithsonian institution
but one in particular stands out for
having a link to kristen wiig's past
natasha rothwell plays carol who looks
right past the clumsy barbara minerva
even though barbara reminds her that
carol hired her in the first place
carol appears briefly introducing
barbara and diana
and giving them a heads up about the fbi
wanting the smithsonian's assistance and
identifying several recovered artifacts
including the mysterious stone rothwell
is a veteran both in front of and behind
the camera she has appeared in tv and
films such as sonic the hedgehog
brooklyn nine-nine
and the current iteration of ducktales
she is the voice of zan
alson an owl businesswoman and mayor of
saint canard she's also an executive
story editor on the hbo comedy insecure
and was a writer on saturday night live
from 2014 to 2015
during wig's heyday camera might not
recognize barbara minerva at first sight
but it's likely that rothwell and wig
shared some snl stories between takes
wonder woman 1984 includes several
character actors
some of whom have other pop culture
appearances one of those is stewart
milligan who plays the president of the
united states the real president
in 1984 was ronald reagan at the time
the oldest person ever to be nominated
by a major party for the office
milligan doesn't try to imitate reagan
but plays his role straight
his president finds his appointment
calendar suddenly cleared for a meeting
with maxwell lord
thanks to lord wishing his way to the
top of the list diana tries to intercept
the lord at the white house
leading to a fight sequence against both
an empowered barbara and animal prince
and the secret service
with steve providing backup if milligan
looks familiar perhaps it's because he
previously played president richard
nixon
during a 2011 story arc on doctor who he
also voiced colonel stark in the 2009
animated miniseries doctor who dreamland
and appeared in other sci-fi films
such as sky captain in the world of
tomorrow and outland
wonder woman 1984 gives diana both her
iconic costume and gold armor with wings
a reference to the ceremonial battle
armor the amazon artisan palace created
for her
as extra protection whenever facing an
extremely powerful villain
in the film the armor has a different
origin story queen hippolyta tells a
young diana about a brave amazon
named asteria who wore the golden armor
to protect her sister's retreat to
themschira when they left the regular
world diana later relates this legend to
steve
explaining how she's recovered the
golden armor of asteria over her years
of working with antiquities diana later
wears the armor as extra protection
during the film's climax
yet a post-credit scene reveals that
asteria didn't die while protecting that
ancient retreat
she's been living among us too played by
linda carter
tv's original live-action wonder woman
from the 1970s
the cameo is an obvious tribute to the
beloved carter who at dc
fandom in 2020 thanked jenkins and
gaddut for their treatment of the iconic
character
according to carter seeing jenkins and
gadit's interpretation of wonder woman
made her own daughter
finally understand what the character
was all about she said mom
i finally get it i finally get
what wonder woman means to everyone
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite superhero movies are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one
you